- What is your ideal body type?
- [Woman] I would say
someone who's like, fit.
Someone who could definitely
just like throw me around.
Yeah.
(girls giggle and agree)
- Noted.
(upbeat music)
- My name's Maki.
I'm 23 years old.
I'm from Los Angeles, California
and I do social media marketing.
I would say my body type is
someone that's very slim.
Someone that keeps up with themselves.
I wouldn't say tall but just
someone around my height
as long as she's not like three
or four feet taller than me.
(record scratch)
- [Speaker] Okay, I'll...
(overlapping comments)
- Oh wait, sorry, wait, inches.
(girls giggling)
Sorry, I meant inches.
I meant inches, I meant inches.
I'm not the biggest or the strongest
but I know that I have
some great qualities.
So I like my body.
I'm always gonna be
confident about myself.
(bell chimes)
Interesting toes.
(loud laughter from girls)
Very interesting toes.
I'm gonna say there are some people
that do keep up with their toes.
There's also some women
who I feel like my toes look
a little bit better than.
- [Woman] The shade, the shade.
(overlapping voices)
- What is your ideal body type?
- [Sierra] So someone that's fit.
Not really that they
have to be really strong
and very, I guess muscular
but more that they have a
confidence about themselves.
Really the personality like really makes
or breaks if I like them or not.
And that they like the
outdoors and being active
'cause if they can't
do active stuff with me
it's really hard for me to
wanna like connect with them.
- Okay.
- [Maddy] Tall, fit,
but not too big because
I'm kind of a small person.
So not like you can kill me.
- Like they're kidnapping you.
- Yeah.
- You don't need to be a gym
rat or look like Chris Evans.
Although he's pretty fine.
And Captain America's
ass could like, you know
I'd be down with it, but you don't need
to look like that for
me to be like into you.
- I do prefer somebody
who's taller than me.
The most I'll go shorter
than me is like two inches.
Um.., I'm sorry, babe, not
two feet, but two inches.
(laughter)
- I would say someone who's like fit
and takes care of themselves.
Someone who could definitely
just throw me around, yeah.
(giggles of agreement)
- That's a turn, that's a turn.
- Noted.
- I have dated people of
like all different heights
and body types, so I
don't, I don't discriminate
over here, baby, I mean...
- I noticed the tattoo
"bittersweet" and I gotta say
I really dig that.
- Thank you, I appreciate it.
- Now, are you lovely
ladies into tattoos at all?
- Oh hell, yes.
(overlapping agreement)
- Okay, music to my ears, I have three.
- Okay, you gotta catch
up baby, I got like eight.
- Oh shoot.
- I had six.
- Quite a few of us
back here have tattoos.
- I only have two, I feel like....
- On our next date, we
could go to a tattoo shop.
(bell chimes)
(upbeat music)
- I'm probably going to have
to go based on the feet.
I love the answers from
this one, but I'm going
to have to eliminate number one.
- Oh, hi, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Hey, you got tattoo.
- I do.
- Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too.
- I don't know, they
just, they were the only
ones not really done.
- Yeah, I hike and like lift.
So nail polish just gets rubbed off.
- Aw.
- Yeah.
- I like going hiking too.
- I messed up.
(bell chimes)
- Okay so some are a little bit revealing
and others, I see shorts.
- Yeah.
- Okay, what's up with the shorts?
- My parents are going
to watch this and...
- Hi parents.
- Yeah.
- This is like conservative,
I think for me.
- Whoa, conservative, okay, okay, nice.
And then number five?
Oh, there's a lot of tattoos over there.
I like that.
- Yeah! (giggles)
- Nice tattoos.
- Yeah, I have like little
kind of random bangers all
over like little stick
and poke style ones.
I'm a stripper, so I'm
like, in my underwear
for a living, so this is also
very conservative for me.
- Okay, a stripper, what's
what's your favorite
thing about stripping?
- The money.
- The Money! (laughter)
- I went a little bit more conservative.
This is not the norm, I
just, you know, I think there
is something to leaving a little something
to the imagination.
- Right, right, now
there was someone earlier
who mentioned being thrown around?
(laughter) - Um... hi.
- Now I have a personalized
question for you.
- Oh no.
What's your biggest turn on?
- Um., probably, oh no, I can't say that.
(laughter from all girls)
I would just say like someone who cares
about pleasing the other
person more than themselves.
- Okay, how comfortable
are you in your own body?
- I think when I was growing up, I wasn't
but then as I got older, honestly
I think that I kind of
had a glow up, but yeah
I'm pretty confident as you kind of tell.
- Shout out to that.
- I'm pretty confident
and comfortable in my
body but it was a process.
Like I don't think it
naturally came to me.
I've always kind of been
like the bigger taller girl
and also being, like, biracial
and growing up with like a white mom.
It took me a lot of time
to kind of be comfortable in my skin.
- Back in school, I used to be made fun of
for being like real skinny,
I'm trying to learn how to love
my body throughout all stages
and be comfortable in it.
No matter what it looks like.
- I'm like cute all the time, so.., yeah.
- Nice.
- We all have our insecurities
and I definitely have some
but I go to the gym a couple times a week
and I've been weight training
for almost like the past year.
And I feel like that's
helped with my confidence
and feeling comfortable with my body alot.
- There's a lot of pressure
in the industry to get plastic
surgery and stuff like that.
And I'm very pro plastic surgery.
But it is something that, you
know, just being around a lot
of people who have it, you
think like maybe do I need it?
Should I get it, but I'd
say for the most part
I am pretty confident in my body.
- [All] Yeah!
- I like that, we love
a confident queen too.
- How confident are you in your body?
- Yeah.
- I'm definitely confident in my body.
- Oh!
- Yeah, I can tell.
(laughter)
- Yeah.
(bell chimes)
- How many am I eliminating this round?
- Two.
- Oh God.
- Okay, oh my gosh.
I'm going to eliminate number three.
(bell chimes)
- Okay.
- Bye babes.
(giggles)
- Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too.
- Oh, I like your tattoos.
- Thank you.
- Damn!
- We'll link up, it's cool, see ya.
- Damn, this is hard as hell, like I don't
want to eliminate anybody.
Number two.
(bell chimes)
- Hi.
- Hi, I'm Angelica, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you as well.
I thought you were
gonna be taller than me.
So I was like...yeah.
- Yeah, like I'm tall,
it'd be like it's okay.
No harm, no foul, it's okay.
- Take care.
(bell chimes)
- Okay so let's see.
What's your least favorite
thing on your body?
- Either my boobs or my nose.
- Okay.
- I don't think I'd ever
get a boob job though.
Even though like I'm kind
of insecure by my boobs.
I don't wanna be like, yeah
I'm gonna do what you want me to do.
So I'm gonna do the opposite instead.
- What does that key mean?
- It's the key to my heart.
- I like that.
- You want it? I'm gonna
have to take that right now.
- I'm confident, and I'm happy
with the body type I have.
But at the same time
if I'm feeling insecure
or if I'm experiencing
like body dysmorphia
or anything like that, it's
almost a situation where it's
not accepted for me to have
those insecurities or voice them
because somebody might be a
different type of body type
that's more targeted in
a bad way with society.
- So I will say like being a
curvier girl, I do have like
obviously like more belly and more leg
than a lot of like Instagram
models and stuff do.
Obviously like everyone
has their angles and stuff,
but you could like kinda
hide that a little bit.
- Why are you single and what
do you look for in a partner?
- I'm single because probably
because of my bad taste
in guys, I've only been in
one relationship technically
and we never even labeled
it because it was just
so toxic and honestly
like emotionally abusive.
- I would say I'm single right now
just because I'm a very
picky person, I'm open
to going out and casually
dating and just having fun.
I'm not necessarily like looking
for the one or like anything.
- I actually moved out
here from the east coast
with my ex at the time.
So put on my best clown makeup
and came out here and it did not work out.
It did not work out.
I'm looking for someone that's wholesome.
(bell chimes)
- Okay, so the person I'm going
to have to eliminate
unfortunately is number three.
- Hi.
- Damn, I love your hair, that's sick.
- Hi, hi Emily.
- I'm Maki, nice to meet to you.
- Nice to meet you, what's up?
- I love your tattoos.
- Thank you, I like your tattoos.
- You have a nice story.
- Thank you, you do have
nice, he has really has nice
eyes by the way, he really does.
- Thank you, I appreciate that.
I like the hearts.
- Thank you.
- I'm going to have to
eliminate number two.
(bell chimes)
- Hi.
- I'm Christina. I'm
Maki, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Damn, I don't know.
Like you just seem very shy.
I like your answers though.
- I got like the same glasses as you.
- You do?
- What's your vision, are
you near a farsighted?
- I am near side where you can see, right?
Right, yeah.
- Give, give, give.
- You wanna take my
glasses, okay, for sure.
Can I see with the... oh, yours...
I don't know.
(laughter)
- It's like 3D, Huh?
- It's like a little
stronger than mine, so yeah.
- Oh, I know, I'm sorry.
- Don't be sorry, you good.
- It was nice meeting you.
- Thank you.
- Come on out.
- Hi.
- Hello, I'm Maki.
- Can I hug you? (giggles)
- Yeah, of course, I've
been hugging everyone.
- Hello.
- Hi I'm Maddy.
- You have nice tattoos and
I like your answers as well.
Especially with the
key to the heart thing,
that one was dope, that was dope.
I'm definitely excited to
see like what happenes.
- This is awkward eye contact right now.
(nervous laughter)
- Can I have your number, instagram?
- Y'all actually do make
like really cute couples.
So like if y'all don't date I'mma be mad.